Speaker 1: OK, let's speak to some people.
We do now speak to folks through The David
Pakman Show discord, which now has, I don't
know, twelve, thirteen, fourteen thousand
people subscribe to it.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
Let's start today with Steve from Asheville,
Steve from Asheville.
You were on the air.
What's going on?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, how are you doing today?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Yeah, it's funny, I woke up like 15 minutes
ago and still waking up, but I saw you were
doing this and I'm
Speaker 1: well, hopefully awake enough to
have a coherent question.
Speaker 4: Yes, yes, sir.
All right, so my question for you is, what
do you make of all this pipeline issues that's
happening?
I live in, you know, Asheville, North Carolina,
and we're seeing long lines at the gas stations.
Hardly gas anywhere.
Yeah.
What is this going to end, David?
Speaker 1: From what I'm reading, this is
going to be resolved possibly by the end of
this weekend.
I mean, I don't know that I have any more
up to date information than you have.
Speaker 4: OK, how do you think Joe Biden
and his administration are going to respond
to this?
I have heard that there's I guess I don't
know if it's a conspiracy or if it's confirmed
that this was from Russia.
Speaker 1: I have not heard that.
What I have heard was that it is related to
a site.
The method of attack was cyber.
But I and I may just be behind on the issue.
I've not even heard it asserted that it was
Russia.
So I would want to look into that.
But I think the Biden administration response
will depend on what we ultimately know about
it.
I just don't know if that's definitive.
And I think I want to be careful about speculating,
of course.
Or are you going out and, like, filling bags
with gas like we've seen some people do?
Speaker 4: No, no, I thankfully, I, I happen
to get gas on Sunday before this all happened.
I'm, I'm doing well, but yeah.
No, people are panic filling up gas.
I saw I did see someone I work for a company
where you know where delivery and I saw people
filling up canisters three, four or five at
a time.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's actually ridiculous.
I saw one video of a woman filling up a plastic
bag with gas.
And it's like once you get it into the car,
what do you like when you're holding the bag
in the air?
That could work, but then how do you set it
down?
It just didn't really make any from the standpoint
of of mechanical physics.
I wasn't understanding it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah, I mean, maybe she's
come up with some sort of, you know, metaphysical
strategy that we're just not yet understanding
like mere mortals like us,
Speaker 1: there was something there that
made me think I may not understand the principles
of solids, gases and liquids.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I mean, yeah, she could just be on a different
plane of existence, like, I don't know, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, how's vaccination going down there?
Speaker 4: Good, you know, I live in Ashville,
which is kind of, you know, it's kind of a
jewel in the midst of the south.
Yeah, I'm personally vaccinated myself.
Beautiful.
Both Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's going good on my and my friends are
getting vaccinated.
Apparently the numbers are going down though,
and for the for the country.
And I'm a little nervous about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they're going.
They did but they are actually ticking back
up now.
And with 12 to 15 year olds able to get Fizer,
I think I think we're on the up and up.
I really think we're going to be looking pretty
good by Memorial Day.
Speaker 4: Well, David, starting off my day,
that's wonderful news because I've been ignoring
pleasure, because I got a little little little
scared, a little nervous, but, you know.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, I appreciate
the call.
Thank you.
Thank you, David.
Take care.
All right.
So a big issue, gasoline still necessary for
so much of our daily lives